Lucas wrote in saying what cliche quote
do you hate the most I've mentioned one
of the ones I really dislike which is
we'll have to agree to disagree but I
don't know if that qualifies as a cliche
quote another one that really bothers me
is everything happens for a reason
because it is both completely true and
meaningless right I mean in a sense yes
effects have causes and without getting
metaphysical or religious about it
that's just sort of a reality what
things happen there are reasons why
things happen and even though they may
be random in a sense or maybe they may
be related merely to the odds or
probability of them happen and yes
things happen for a reason so there's
that it's meaning within that sense and
then if the other thing is listen your
life is predestined predetermined
there's no free will
well I might as well not even really try
to make decisions because pay lists and
things just happen for a reason I'm
never going to know those reasons so I
might as well just not worry about it
and not worry about decisions that I
make I find it to be devoid of meaning
you know what quote I hate it is what it
is of course it is what it is that's
what it is what else would it be okay
alright yeah I mean it's meaningless it
doesn't really do anything I guess it's
sort of meant to say this is where we
are and we can only now make decisions
based on this there's no point in
talking about how things could be
different
yeah how about money can't buy happiness
I mean that's true to some extent that I
complex money gives you a platform to
which you can find yourself in a happier
place no any more so than if you're
struggling to get by yeah I mean there's
a lot of research on that concept and of
course life satisfaction is different
than happiness and there are different
studies about well does money beyond a
certain purchasing power actually lead
to more happy people or people who are
more satisfied with their lives it's not
even completely true
that money doesn't buy happiness yeah
I've seen studies as to like showing
maybe you're on 70 to 80 thousand
dollars that's where people are happiest
but I really know yeah it's and and it's
very it's a difficult thing to measure
I'm kind of thinking there's any other
but we say cause good things come to
those
wait yeah unless you wait too long yeah
I mean I guess it's to this idea that
you should be determined and keeps
driving at your goals but patient you
should be patient but you can't just let
opportunities pass you by either yeah
yeah I I find a lot of these clothes are
kind of pointless like what if you see a
good-looking person at a bar that you
want to approach when you wait too long
and someone else gets to the head of
good things would have come to you if
you had just waited longer I guess yeah
it doesn't really make sense on there
but I guess at the top of my list are
everything's everything happens for a
reason and we have to agree to disagree
also if all was fair in love and war we
wouldn't have war crimes if all I've
never even heard that one oh really
I mean I know the whole nothing's fair
in love and war but I've never heard if
all was fair in love and war and have
war crimes maybe it's not go eat Raven I
think you just made it up okay yeah